TELEVISION ABOUT THIS BEFORE.ERS
UNRS BETWE CHARLIE
IKREORER W A.OR AKED
IT>>ORAROUNDSENNTE PNU
I
HAOUAN ER
SS GA FSPWAIGOP
SNTTE BFE RTHAKE>>ANE ASREIDO
R
UREN>> CLI P T M YOANTAORHA I PE
OS D HLOUASOLGHNYAS  HGIGEI H TR
T AT
UR
OOU WPR
EP
ADWHHIS
REON AEL WLICI Y SALE
OENOU
LE  TN WEOENNMSIE ID T
N'OR
E'UREHEAALPB H WND.D
F,T, DILERCAEID I W>>RGOFZAOPMU
OC
HNIRO CALSOELORY? LHEOS FAR K I
IETTNIAT AHTTOHESVENGOUAYL R
T A
'RT I HA
NT  AO ASPLTI TENABBL
WAINEA HIDITIN
NOOWO
PR
YI SE CHI T WHI  AEW A"AYFT NJOA
LOVE PSSS INOS ISET I'CHED ABUO
OUES FNKTHG TRK
WO  OOMOUNDBO UR HIZONES
TIUEMOHI TNT  O TWRKUEDEDNGM,END
SI  W AWNTORINCOHA.  RKUTLD
TUTHI UNAAP TER, D  PTU MESHERI
WVA LEXLT TND C AORAK T BLTLID
W INT D
LIPYHES FO SETINT
OU TL IBS O TNEARHIOUOMHESIUAOMO
ON O HO C
ANHA.T TRETAB WREVELMU SNTIN AE
WCOEFFYO
. WOWWAUREALN
OFAVBS NDETENOHIOUE' WNIITTEHO S
Q THAOMTV I
HIN
DEN DORME AECRDPE
AEPE DRE WHE.ULO T HHAVEEBCAASB
OPIDGEERRE
DNOT BAC>>I HNSI B TIE TRKLESEHL
O T OXINAS
WCHSHTH A
ASRA'TEX .RE A WN PHIS ANINKE TI
HAAROWIST ON'TI WPE
DALLHE MUTNKT.NIDTHHEE,NISM HLII
TOOWREOR F